HA-HA-HA!
IT'S SO GREAT!
>> Tucker: WE HAVEN'T A LOT OF
UFO STORIES LATELY.
THE PHENOMENON SEEMS TO BE
ACCELERATING.
THE GOVERNMENT DETAILS MORE THAN
150 CASES OF UNEXPLAINED UFO
ENCOUNTERS IN THE PAST YEAR.
IN ALL, THIS REPORT LOOKED INTO
MORE THAN 300 TOTAL ENCOUNTERS,
AND OF THOSE HALF COULD NOT BE
EXPLAINED.
AN AMAZING STORY REALLY.
150.
JOSH BOSWELL IS THE REPORTER AT
"THE DAILY MAIL" WHO BROKE THE
STORY, AND JOINS US.
JOSH, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A LOT.
OVER WHAT PERIOD WERE THESE 150
UNEXPLAINED SIGHTINGS?
>> IT COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY
MORE THAN 150, BUT IT'S OVER ONE
YEAR.
THE PREVIOUS REPORT WE HAD WAS
143 UNEXPLAINED CASES FROM 2004
ALL THE WAY UP TO 2021.
SO THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IT SEEMS.
>> Tucker: IT'S AN EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE.
WHAT DOES THIS SUGGEST?
>> PART OF THE ANSWER WILL BE
THAT THE GOVERNMENT IS NOW
LOOKING FOR THESE THINGS.
THEY HAVE MUCH BETTER REPORTING
PROCEDURES.
IF AN F-18 PILOT COMES ACROSS
ONE OF THOSE THESE OBJECTSES
THAT'S HOVERING AROUND THE SEA
THEY'RE FLYING AROUND, THEY'RE
MORE LIKELY TO REPORT IT NOW
BECAUSE THERE'S A PROPER
PROCEDURE IN PLACE.
I'M HEARING WE'RE ENCOUNTERING
MORE AND MORE OF THESE THINGS
FROM SOURCES THAT I SPEAK TO, A
PHENOMENA NOT GOING AWAY, AND
NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> Tucker: THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
SPECULATION ABOUT THIS.
THERE WAS A "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" PIECE RECENTLY THAT
SUGGESTED THIS IS A PSY-OP BY
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, TO DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION AWAY FROM THE
FACT THIS IS MILITARY HARDWARE
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT HAS AND
WANTS TO KEEP SECRET.
WHAT'S YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
BELIEVE ABOUT THESE OBJECTS?
>> THE SOURCES THAT I HAVE ARE
TELLING ME THEY JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT THESE THINGS ARE.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A PROPORTION
OF THESE CASES, 366 IN THIS
CLASSIFIED REPORT, THAT'S GOING
TO CONGRESS PROBABLY TOMORROW
THAT ARE EXPLAINED, THAT ARE
CHINESE DRONES, FOR EXAMPLE, BUT
THE UNEXPLAINED ONES THEY HAVE
NO CLUE, BECAUSE THESE THINGS
ARE MOVING IN WAYS THAT WE JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND.
HYPERSONIC SPEEDS, AND THEN THEY
TURN ON A DIME.
I MEAN, IT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> Tucker: IT WOULD SEEM STRANGE
IF THE GOVERNMENT WAS CALLING
ATTENTION TO ITS OWN CLASSIFIED
WEAPONS PROGRAMS.